I've been waiting I was review life by
oh I love that dirt3 - oh my god you
were right
yeah due to an earlier injury dan is
currently nursing his wounds with a bit
of water but this video is about
barbecues a lot of people like to
barbecue
you know steak burgers sausages maybe
you flip some ribs tasty huh
we like to barbecue butane gas
she's get it
that was awesome
where did it go I've no idea John the
slo-mo it just goes didn't come now
let's just say doing a rocket it was so
forceful it blew out all the flames and
didn't even that you can make a fire we
want it to ignite perhaps what we should
do is have some barbecues about doobies
away next time and so blow up and then
Kleber we'll revisit this one in future
yeah well where the hell did it go
maybe it's in orbit is it in space don't
y'all know that ah and your grandparents
are inside probably wondering what the
skadoosh what the okay maybe a maybe
butane barbecue not such a good idea son
all right here's take two we're gonna do
that again with a few modifications not
gonna stand over here whoa
it's gonna be good
black smoke you nervous no I was nervous
with the diet coke and mentos but not
with this good you're nervous you look
like scared schoolboy
I heard there's explosions various
explodes under the various explosions
don't let's drop some science on some of
this
alright say girls get on good let's go
too fast in there I thought it were any
of them landed I think I heard one of
the man behind me but I'll say they went
that way
I thought they did up in the field what
I think there's something every one when
that way I wish we had a camera on the
ground just polygons yes sir
she's no match no no way we do I get ya
alright let's try and figure out because
right that block is just hovering in the
air for ages it is this point the cat is
that yeah there so that shows you how
slow we were actually recording hello
honey free it was 2005 were afraid of
sex or so a hundred times fun it's 100
times slower than playback and that is
fast so this we can figure out how fast
it's going okay how how big can you say
that was like yeah I was probably bout
that big wasn't it well from there maybe
three meters something that yeah okay so
say three meters I love that well I did
I miss yeah there's no there's no
scalable yeah okay so we got the timer
yeah okay with 16 seconds okay
one two okay about three seconds after
three seconds so three seconds three
meters so what so hang in in real time
what is it I took three seconds so in
real time that was naught point naught 3
of a second real time second
360-thousand divide that by a thousand
because we did it meet its own company
yeah and that gives us kilometers which
is 360 yep bit Siri are you joking oh so
mothers do I have no desire for it ah
good enough confirm 360 kilometers into
miles see your question 223 miles an
hour
all right that's a fast can that's like
a sports car
let's don't put cans of butane on your
barbecue
if we did that calculation completely
wrong do you feel free to matter that
might be totally wrong but yeah see if
you come up with similar figures that
was very approximate life yeah roughly
roughly roughly 3a is roughly three
seconds but yeah over 100 miles an hour
definitely